mr. Muhammad Allah Salaam alaikum peace
be with you
I'm Eddie your host you're watching the
Deen show today we're going to be
talking about family business family
business family is the crust of society
if we have broken homes we're going to
have broken society so here at the Deen
show we care about the society we care
about ourselves we care about you and we
want the families to say together so it
starts with yourself and then you go
ahead and get that beautiful spouse and
you fall in love and you want to stay in
love and you want to raise the children
in a beautiful functional family so they
can grow up to be the best Muslims that
they can be contributing to society in a
positive way not a destructive way so
how do we keep families from breaking
and losing the most precious business of
all family business we're going to have
to do some family planning and we got to
know our rights and roles and
responsibilities so we're going to be
back in a minute with Imam was the firs
aid to talk more about this topic here
on the Deen show we'll be right back
this is the thing
I'm in the studio with Imam Mustapha
Zaid who's the author of the lies about
Mohammed you have your own personal
section at the Deen show calm so people
can go back they like this show then go
back to the Deen show calm to see some
of the other shows that we've done with
you
inshallah God willing you have been an
imam spiritual leader yes for how long
about 8 years now 8 years yes now tell
us have you had a lot of experience with
people coming to you husbands wives
complaining
the wife complain about the husband
husband complain about the wives saying
you know look my marriage my life is in
shambles how do we save this I got kids
I got family I don't want it to be torn
apart have you had a lot of these issues
Committee on all the time not all the
time all the time and actually the the
worst part and which I want to alert the
viewers to if you'd ever think that
things would escalate to a level that
you would need any man to interfere do
that early on one of the biggest
mistakes that people do is that they
come to us and we can't make a
difference we can explain to people
things about how to what about your
marriage lives more importantly your
rights and obligations that a husband as
a wife but they come to us after
everything is said and done and there's
too much damage so the there's an advice
that when I put at the outset please go
to your Imam your religious leader early
on when the problem is you know easy to
solve and do not be embarrassed to bring
it to the public because he's not going
to publicize it but he can get in and
interfere in your favor and the favor of
your marriage any children much sooner
than and much better than he can think
creator of the heavens and earth the one
guy the same God of G
as Moses Abraham and the last a
fundamental problem having peace be upon
him Allah in Aramaic jesus said allaha
so we're talking about the crater of the
Sun and the moon the crater this whole
universe and everything in it he's the
most merciful so he sent the blueprint
but now don't things get a little bit
off-track things get in shambles when we
go away from the blueprint is that where
you see most of the problems coming and
stemming from absolutely and and and I
think one major problem in Islamic
upbringing an Islamic education God with
God blessing we have a lot of Islamic
schools is that we do not have a special
section for in Islamic education Islamic
upbringing to show the boy how to be a
good husband what does it take to be a
good husband what are the references
what's the right thing to do and the
wrong thing to do and the same thing for
girls what is a good wife how good can
you be what can you tolerate what can
you tolerate what's good and what's bad
it's very critical because it's about
forming as you said the crust of our
society and if boys and girls do not
know how and they're gonna just go by
trial-and-error then it's a 50/50 chance
for that marriage to happen and that's
what happens sometimes
unfortunately now you don't do that if
you are put in charge of a multi-billion
dollar company
you don't just test and trial you do
your research don't you you really look
into how we can make this right cuz you
don't want to lose your investment you
don't want to lose your money but isn't
family more important than any kind of
business they do job training job
orientation they make sure that you
qualified you have the proper education
before you even start at the bottom of
the ladder then that that's a very good
example and marriage should be dealt
with the same way it's it's about the
future of the children about the future
of the the human being it's about
comfort that the most beautiful one of
the most beautiful verses about marriage
in the universe not even on the Koran
women AIT and Holika Holika women who
succumb as legend leta school alaihe wa
jalla been Akuma the Tamarama and some
of the miracles of allah subhanaw taala
and the blessing of allah subhanaw taala
is that he created from you spouses that
you would use a spiritual home latest
khun wilai hat the schooner a second is
calmness and peace ängelholm spiritual
home for you is where you
go and feel yourself you feel protected
you feel you're safe you recharge your
batteries and so and so forth that's the
spouse that's the hospital wife in Islam
and that's the wife to a husband in
Islam so that is very important that is
the quality of life good marriage is the
good quality of life and good children
good upbringing on someone that you can
trust and someone that you can relate to
and someone who can understand you that
feeling of not having that person or
having a problem at that area is
devastating to the quality of life in
anyone in any religion in any time of
history we know that in Islam which
simply means to acquire peace by
submitting your will to the one God now
Islam there's no dating there's no
test-drive no boyfriends and girlfriends
yes you have to come together in
marriage correct yes so now in the
marriage the the business of family you
know this is an introduction that we
gave that man and women come together
and they're it's a mercy from the crater
but we have roles and responsibilities
so let's talk a little bit about the
man's role and the woman's role because
when we get these roles mixed up I think
a lot of the problems also stuff from
here when the woman starts act like a
man the man stars Ida woman everything's
all messed up we're not playing our
roles yes and this can be linked back
also to business you got the CEO you got
the manager so things function smoothly
Allah wants it to function smoothly he's
given us rose what are these roles he
said a very important couple of words in
the beginning and it's very important I
was interviewed by Bridges TV one time
back in New Jersey and the men asked me
has three question doesn't it make sense
to you that people should be dating
first before they get into marriage
because if things are not getting along
together with you know between them and
the chemistry's not there then you might
as well not start the match from the
beginning and save yourself the hassle
and divorce and all that and my answer
to him and this is why dating is
forbidden Islam it's not what do you
think is good or not it's after you get
married
what do you adhere to mmm what are you
reference to fried and wrong no matter
whom you like and what do you think and
that's what makes a marriage successful
it's what guidelines you abide by if the
wife abide by the guidelines of Islam
and the husband abides by that
guidelines of Islam that's a successful
marriage
which backgrounds they have and that's
the most important thing guidelines
guidelines foul lines perimeters that we
don't go out absolutely the number one
rule in Islam that a man compliments a
woman and a woman compliments a men in
Western societies the man-made
theologies is that they're in
competition which you thought each other
as if they're roommates or partners in a
business and it's my share against you
share or what are you doing versus what
I'm doing totally the opposite in Islam
and man compliments the woman you need
the two elements of life the strength
the perseverance to go out there make a
living protect and provide for the
family
and at the same time you need the
blessing from allah subhanaw taala
upon us that is called a mother the
kindness that love the compassion the
teaching the education the care that is
needed for us men and women to be
brought up in a nice good environment
healthy environment you cannot have that
kindness and mercy and patience in the
same body of strength and perseverance
and fighting you need two elements and I
lost my I made it that way so we
complement each other so we need each
other
the more female a woman is is the more
she would enjoy her being the more manly
a man would be is the more that he's
going to enjoy his being and they
complement each other in that unit like
any unit and he you brought in
beautifully the business example there's
no business that is successful that has
three CEOs or two CEOs and by three CEOs
sometimes it's the wife want to be the
boss and the husband want to be the boss
and they bring even outside influence
from outside family members that
actually dictate and mandate and
influence their life that business is
doomed regardless what resources the
quality of the people involved that
business is going down marriage is not
gonna happen
there has to be a boss allah subhanaw
taala gave that leadership to the man
with the responsibilities of providing a
tribunal and they save him Alfaro men
attend and this is one of the worst
mistranslated words in the quran kawaman
does not mean better
it means attend to the the the the
building attended is the one who serves
all the tenants not the boss of all the
tenants so men attend to the needs of
the family and the women with what Allah
Subhan Allah had give him and what their
ability to spend and provide so
even their attendant you know
availability is conditioned upon your
ability as a man to provide but with
that responsibly the woman also has
responsibility and being the boss of
that business unit does not mean like
some Muslim brother would do my word is
my word it is what it is and I'm the
boss and no you consult you bring the
consensus you want to treat him good
profit from Hama sorry I seldom give the
advice that really come Yeti him let me
say him your best are your best to the
women the mother the daughter the sister
most importantly the wife in his last
speech from Hamas and Salam when he was
carried to the podium to give his last
feature get three pieces advice do not
let the world tempt you and waste you
like a wasted the people before you do
not lose your prayers and of all Islamic
law and all the advice that he gave us
over 23 years the third one was I gave
you a trust that is the women you took
him by the trust of Allah subhana Allah
you know keep that trust treat him well
and problem homicide Saladin matters of
war with men and soul and he's the
prophet of God was the most consulting
of his companions imagine now your
husband and a wife
and she's your life partner and you want
to ensure decision without at least
consulting here you have the ultimate
decision but it has to represent the
best and you have to care and be nice
and lenient as we said before about
promises Amidala's wives
let's take a break when we right back
with more here on the Deen show
there always be someone that'll be there
to say something negative but at the
same time there'll be someone there to
say something positive awesome just hold
onto the Rope of Allah everything in
this universe can rely I need Allah the
Quran says don't kill women don't kill
children don't kill old people don't
attack the civilians this is what the
Prophet Muhammad told us you know Allah
said that the Prophet SAW shall have
never ever stopped a war against any of
us from back here on the Deen show we're
talking about keeping the families
together and we need to know our roles
the man and before we left off to be
kind to the woman to be understanding to
consult with her not to be a dictator in
a house right yeah and this is his role
to maintain the woman she can sit back
and take care of the institution of the
home I'll bring the children is this
right and the man is the one who is what
some would look for a sugar daddy he
takes care of everything the phone bill
the electric bill she don't have to pay
for anything is this right absolutely
and and one other misconception that I
think was the detriment for many
marriages is that people belittle the
best and most noble job in the history
of mankind that is the job of a mother
promise I am in the middle of 7th
century mandated that even women
captives of enemy combatants would be
educated that women in general re even
Muslim would be educated why because you
have the know most noble job of raising
and educating the entire society men and
women it's our mothers who taught us how
to pray what's right what's wrong gave
us our manners and stayed with us and
helped us with our homework and so on
and so forth that is the greatest job
ever and a lot of people think that you
know because the wife was an engineer or
a doctor how could she be a housewife as
if a housewife is something bad actually
a good housewife is what makes a great
society a great nation and bring out the
best in men and women so people need to
actually understand men and women the
importance of what is called a mother my
mother god bless her soul was very
highly educated woman and if anyone
shaped my character
you know with the Bliss of a lot of Hana
that it was my mother she was with me
she taught me how to read write what are
the meaning of good words when I read
books that are way older than money my
level it was my mother who taught me
everything yes she could have got a
better job and actually worked outside
and we're gonna have a lot more income
but the impact she had upon my life and
the life of my brother was billions of
dollars worth whatever money that you
brought extra so the value of the ethics
and the quality of people that you bring
about being a good qualified Muslim
mother is much more better than any
materialistic value or extended vacation
or a bigger plasma TV so that is that is
something that I think a lot of people
need to grasp as far as Islamic values
when it comes to marriage now the
influence of outside television media
would belittle sometimes this position
but this is very very detrimental like
you said to the upbringing of the future
leaders of the world yes having an
educated woman that is really protecting
that child nurturing that child rather
than Sally or Betsy or whoever a house
raising that child and or the TV all day
put the put the mother whose got the
formula of Mercy patients to really make
sure that this child grows up to be
someone or a woman or man it's gonna be
a asset a benefit for society and just a
short indication of how rewarded that
the greatness of a good mother a good
Muslim mother the man that came to a
problem as I said I wanted to do jihad
which is being drafted to the army of
the Muslims you wanted to get that
reward from allah subhanaw taala from
mosul S&D your mother is alive he said
yes
he said is a hub for intelligent at the
tactical that may have go serve her
because paradise that you seek and by
making jihad for the sake of allah
subhanaw taala is underneath the feet of
your own mother serving his mother
supersedes the great reward of being you
know a soldier in the muslim army and
that honor you know when you say a human
being that the Paradise or Jenna under
neither field that is honoring the job
and the noble status of a mother that a
lot of people belittle so we know that
the woman in Islam has been uplifted God
Almighty has given her
rights and we will in Charlotte do a
show about the women's rights and roles
in Islam which far precede any rights
that many of the women today today you
maybe you can elaborate on this but now
she's also got responsibilities so we
talked about the man now the man is the
one who provides who takes care who he's
the one who goes out in the cold and
pumped the gas and you know hustle and
bustle and you know take care of you
know the responsibilities is this
correct nauseous and he has to be kind
and merciful consult with his wives his
wife and at the end of the day he does
all this what is the also the role of
the man in the house as far as should
the woman once consulted because you
also have some nightmare stories where
the woman now you know because we live
in the Jerry Springer Society nobody
gonna tell me what to do so should the
attitude of the wife be when the husband
tells her you know look a law tells us
this the messenger tell her that we
should do it this way and now she wants
to do it her way
ain't nobody gonna tell me what to do is
this the right attitude that is the
wrong attitude and people need to
understand but you know Muslim men and
Muslim women that obeying the husband as
far as the wife is obeying allah
subhanaw taala the general cardinal rule
in islam lotta Thelema luke fema seattle
highland there's no obedience to a
created in disobeying the creator so if
he tells you things that is Islamic ly
correct then he is to be obeyed because
in obeying him you will be in allah
subhanaw taala
and he also when he gives that it's not
an order she's not employed by you she's
not a servant she is your partner in
life and when he say things then that
when the boss gives an order in a
business to the vice president or the
the division director this needs to be
done it needs to be done if there's an
issue to be brought discuss it nicely
and politely would be understanding that
the ultimate decision and ended the
ultimate responsibility before a loss of
hanataro lies with whoever is entrusted
to run the business promises an
undescribed
an obedient righteous woman as a
treasure of this world treasure and
actually in another hand is the
you wanna know what the treasure of
dunya of this world it's a good wife if
you look at her she would please you if
you leave her her money you would trust
her with you money if you leave your
children with her you you would trust
her with you with your children when you
are away she would keep her chastity
it's a form of a source of pleasure
about calmness trust and confidence and
that's a beautiful thing and look at the
reward for that and a lot of women do
not know where the reward is promised
asylum said if the woman did four things
if she prayed her five prayers if she
fasted her 30 days if she kept her
chastity if she obeyed her husband and
as we said obeying allah subhanaw taala
in the husband then on Judgment Day it
would be told to her enter Jannah from
whichever door you want
it's put right up there with the prayer
and the fasting this is a major thing
and as the CEO the president the person
that Allah put in charge because Allah
the Creator knows best in his wisdom
he's made it like this absolutely and
you know there's there's a role for the
wife in Islam that a lot of even Muslim
wives are not aware of but by experience
they practice it you become the mother
of the husband at the fact to one
whether directly indirectly the mother
who takes care of him like his mother
took care for him and the mother when
the baby is crying she does not cry back
at him
she understand his pain she tolerate his
pain and deals with it and a lot of
successful marriages come from the level
of tolerance and patient that the
husband and the wife apply and in that
comes the general cardinal rule in Slam
problem Hamza song told us and this is
how we treat people as a major part of
the manners of Islam in limited
lyrica aldrin Feltham islam allah if you
did not find an excuse for your part
they did something wrong then seek an
excuse for him if you're not find an
excuse make one up for him and that it
needed to be applicable in one's life as
a Muslim it is in his marriage life my
wife did something wrong yes you would
get angry get mad but trying to find
execute she's busy with the kishida and
the husband would yell and they say
something they be rude or does something
then the wife we see them said that's my
life partner that's the one that I love
that's that my partner for
years it's not because of this thing all
of a sudden he's a monitor she's a demon
you know that may lots of hannett I
would maybe when he will come down and
then and and and and that is how
marriages work not being confrontational
when the wife is mad or doing something
wrong don't make the confrontational now
calm down - and then nicely and politely
say why do you do this didn't you know
that hurt me I thought you did this and
ended that you can diffuse a ton of
divorces and problems by that leniency
and that you know what let's wait till
things calm down and do it their own
amazingamazing and we'll be back with
more here on the Dean show don't go
nowhere I just want to say very simple
message one of the beautiful things
about our religion of Islam is the
emphasis on direct ritual and prayer
things God directly
there is no intermediary the lights will
go on after the party and the party will
end it's very simple and very clear
there are no superstitious rituals no
strange incantations the time is running
out and you might not make it till
tomorrow and this is something that we
need to think about back here on the
Dean show with Imam Mustapha Zaid you
have a lot of experience you are a
religious leader a spiritual leader in
New Jersey
yes so you have a lot of these cases
coming up we want to save the families
we know that divorce is something that
you know what it's there as a last
resort
is it but we don't want people to have
broken home because when we have broken
societies is that correct yes and it's
Hallel yeah it also has allowed it but
in a ball that had Ali and the light to
love the most-hated Hallel or a loud
thing that a lot of panel allowed is
divorce because divorce and a lot of
people do not realize that it has so
many dimensions of damage the the most
apparent one are the children no matter
what happens or what people claim that
you know what when the couple are
divorced you know the mother is gonna
provide or the father is gonna do this
this and that there's nothing like two
loving father and mother together taking
care of the same children children would
have a devastating lasting effect upon
them and that is Haram that's a part of
the responsibility of marriage that when
I say you know what I wanted
or I want to stand up to my husband or
my wife and I'm not going to do this and
you know being stubborn and Shaitaan
gets in between no keep an eye on the
real damage of the lives that a loss of
heart that I trusted you both with
another factor also when it comes to
divorce is that some Muslim men use
divorce as something to bargain with or
pressure you know what I'll divorce you
just to show an impact that you know
your divorce that they're just to scare
her or to get the wife to behave better
that is a very wrong technique the word
divorce is a very heavy word you say it
meaning it and apply divorce two times
the third time she's not your wife
anymore unless she really marries
somebody else and actually get divorced
from that real marriage and then you can
marry a joke it's not a joke
period and when there's a divorce issue
do not let anyone influence what's going
on and get involved only righteous
people that care for the best interest
of the couple can get involved do not
get me a mother-in-law or a father and
loan either side that actually was a
part of the problem by interfering in
the marriage and undermining the
position of the husband let's say or the
right of the wife upon the husband from
let's say somebody of his family and
bring these people to mediate and throw
them in the relationship Allah subhana
Allah says that if you have the good
intention then that marriage inshallah
would be kept so bring all the righteous
people who are wise the common and
interfere to bring the marriage together
and limit outside influence my mother is
sacred to me but my mother is not my
wife my wife has rights upon me as well
and these rights should not affect each
other or take from you know other
persons right
my father is sacred to me but he does
not run my household the same way his
father-in-law did not run his own
household and so on and so forth so
respect family relationships but respect
your wife more than you respect the rest
of the family when it comes to your own
household and vice versa for the wife
that is also a major factor and and what
happens now you mentioned outside
interference yes now from what you're
saying this couldn't have a devastating
negative effect yes I mean it's just one
of the the rights of the husband and
wife that now that she doesn't go out
and she's communicating with other
sisters or the husband's other brothers
now they're getting influenced now from
physicians like what we call the
scholars physicians people who can
really advise you to good according to
the Quran of a grading Word of God and
the Sunnah of last final measure but to
their own opinions their yes way of
thinking what they think is right
oh man he shouldn't be doing that to you
oh you could replace her with something
better
and then they pump up the husband or the
wife in a negative way and they cause
more problems can you elaborate on this
problem homicide said I'm said that if
I'm talking to you and you told me
something and you just turn around
automatically you have given me an Amana
as if you have trusted me with money
that I keep for you repeat that again if
you turn around and I told you something
and I turn around automatically the
moment I turn around as if I gave you
money and I trusted you with an Amana
that you need to keep from me meaning
that for other people even strangers you
should not tell other people
confidential information to other people
the most confidential of all information
is information of your own life you want
household so otherwise do not have a
best friend and telling her the secrets
of the household secrets of intimacy
that is totally forbidden by laws of
Amazo I said I'm gonna lost panatela and
the same thing with the husband yes
their families but there's limits to
knowledge about the day-to-day life the
more you involve these people the more
they're gonna get involved in your life
negatively or positively according to
their own liking
and subhanAllah in the quran call all
the robinus Maliki Nancy Lana's min
Shari Lewis YC Allison s one of the
first effects that allah subhanaw taala
asked us to resort to him from the
Shaitaan is the whispering of the
Shaitaan that whispering sometimes is
done by your best friend and your family
even your parents on time when you
listen when you open the radio channel
to receive that negative influence
you're just opening you know a door to
just destroy your entire marriage and
when the marriage is destroyed who's
gonna suffer you more than anyone else
and your children and your husband and
so many broken you know houses and in
marriages up to three years they wish
that they were lenient and tolerant and
they didn't say what they had to say
and we're not listening to the people
that they listen to but sometimes it's
too late
sometimes it's too late we don't want it
to be too late that's what we're
discussing this so we can save the home
not break the home and we're gonna have
to continue to do a part two to this
because this is such a very very
important topic we're gonna give some
some live examples in the next show
would you agree to come back and do a
longish God willing okay just before we
close just some closing comments and
suggestions for the people who are
suffering now what before we go to the
next program and do this for the
following week what advice do you have
fun I think one of the most practical
pieces of advice is that you bring a
piece of paper and write down the good
things about your spouse just above
things and when you write them down you
would realize that yes your spouse is
not perfect let me break some news to
you but so is everyone so are you so
when you look at these good things about
your spouse it would remind you that
there are qualities there that things to
bargain there and subhanallah the same
people who are so happy about the
marriage that's why they accepted their
spouse in the beginning and got married
all of a sudden they would complain that
he turned to be the devil or turned to
be this and that and and so on so forth
but actually sometimes people would
admit hopefully after when it's not too
late that their tolerance level their
ability to accept the pitfalls of their
spouse actually weighing down through
time with the pressures of life and
responsibilities and sometimes all it
take is just to be apart for 3-4 days in
a vacation or staying with your family
till things calm down and then you would
hear and again to the same spouse that
you loved in the beginning so inshallah
write down the quality of people find
execuse for your spouse you know
sometimes it's just as we said just take
a break for 2-3 days away from
everything and the pressure of the daily
life of marriage and things magically
changing shot a lot of the best
thank you very much does that colloquy
look forward to doing more with you we
are things like a lovely oh yeah and
that was Imam was tough Isaiah the
author of the lies about Mohammed you
can go to his website to purchase the
book and to learn more about him and
I look forward to having you back again
make due out to a loss stick to the game
plan the Koran the verbatim Word of God
in the Sunnah know your roles know your
rights and live by the way they'll bring
you peace and happiness Islam we'll see
you next time here in the D show peace
be unto you you have to pray as if
everything depends on a lot and it does
but you must work that's my point you
see the same and I don't like that I
don't like us sitting here what are you
waiting for
what are we waiting for right now what
are you waiting for all these people
that come to this nah what are you
waiting for what are we waiting for
right now when they're gonna come
they're gonna come to log on bring these
people lost upon the water put in our
hand the ability to do your job
I am Not Afraid I am not afraid to stand
alone if you live by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if you live by my side I am
not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone I am Not Afraid